david Tebbutt and his wife loved to
travel beyond the beaten track the
beautiful resort they chose renowned for
its privacy but ultimately so isolated
it cost him his life the couple both in
their 50s were the only guests here when
gunmen struck killing David before
kidnapping Judith and escaping by boat
back at their home in a quiet Hartford
to town what's happened to them has
proved almost impossible to take in with
judith tebbutt still being held captive
neighbors are reluctant to speak on
camera worried they might say something
which would endanger her further but
they described the couple as well liked
friendly quiet they go off on a run and
be seen doing that regularly but we're
never too busy to stop and chat the
couple had been closely involved with
this on Oliver's school now in his
mid-20s he's believed to be on his way
to Kenya here the head told me his
former teachers have struggled to
maintain their composure complete
devastation really a number of our staff
worked with Ali who was at school here
for for ten years a busy boy in school
and the parents were here a great deal
they were busy in the local community
and we're often supporting him on the
touchline the local vicar sharing his
sentiments it was just such a shock that
this whole thing could happen that
somebody has been on holiday and having
safari and having a holiday of a
lifetime and suddenly the whole thing
has become a brutal murder the incident
on lahmu island isn't the first time
Westerners have been targeted in 2008 to
Italian none to a kidnapped by Somali
gunmen near the border town of El wack a
year later three aid workers were
kidnapped in Mandela but were later
released it's feared this could be the
work of al-shabaab the militant Islamist
group whose training based in raaz
Gamboni is near the Kenyan border this
is a border which is very porous or
though officially closed many times it
never really stops people crossing and
be those many people you know engaged in
perfectly legitimate trade or fleeing
the drought in Somalia but also
criminals smugglers use this border as
well so this is a very volatile region
in la Marie the search operation goes on
having called in the military to help
working alongside the African
authorities officials from the british
foreign office which is appeal to the
kidnappers to show compassion here in
hartford share those who knew Judith
tullett are trying to remain hopeful but
they're still barely able to believe
what's happened to their neighbors
Rachel younger Sky News bishop stortford